c'est le joueur de toute une génération
zizou zinédine zidane l'ancien capitaine
des bleus fête ses cinquante bougies
pour les jeunes les années 90 2000
zidane c'est bien plus qu'un joueur de
foot c'est un modèle une icône elle
représente un peu les immigrés qui joue
en france et ça représente justement une
union entre les immigrés les français
c'est ça et j'adore comment il joue
juste trop bien là une trop bonne
technique à l'époque les jeunes
s'identifient à lui limite ballon au
pied le natif de marseille est aussi le
symbole d'une france black blanc beur de
vainqueur de la coupe du monde 1998
l'appui de noir et appelant notre cdc
français qui ont gagné quand on cite
animal c'est pas c'est pas l'arabe qui a
marqué ou sept français la popularité de
zizou dépasse le cadre du sport les
politiques aussi en parle comme lionel
jospin en 1998 je suis un entraîneur
joueur dit son voile blanc et lainage de
jacquet et de zidane ou encore philippe
seguin en 1999 et zinedine zidane c'est
meilleur pour vous sûrement et puis je
crois que donna au delà de sa qualité de
footballeur je crois que ce qui est
extraordinaire c'est qu'on puisse
disposer avec l'umih à la fois bon un
joueur d'exception et d'une personnalité
aussi attachante
après les jeunes et les politiques iden
est aussi citée par les sociologues et
oui comme robert est dit écoutez le
s'exprimer c'était toujours en 1999 le
sportif et les porteurs de valeurs de
conquête de courage de force
d'abnégation
c'est quelqu'un qui peut oublier la
souffrance et se transcender c'est donc
le super héros celui qui par son action
va transformer le cours des choses
zidane le super héros mais au fait ils
en pensent quoi lui zizou de tout ça
selon lui il a une responsabilité envers
les jeunes oui mais je crois qu'il faut
faut donner l'exemple face et c'est ce
que j'essaie de mes forces de fer
d'essayer de 2 de leur donner leur
montrer le chemin quoi au total zinedine
zidane a été élu six fois personnalités
préférées des français c'est le seul
footballeur à avoir eu ce titre en 2006
le natif de marseille a pris sa retraite
de footballeur depuis 2016 il s'est
reconverti entraîneur et à diriger le
real madrid pendant quatre ans
[Musique]